YES. IS NOW IN SESSION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RADIANCE NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
BSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA OUR QUE HAN. BENNETT
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA. BRIAN
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHEN. CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DAVIES
FLORA MIKE FONG VINCE FONG
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY
LIII LEVINE. LOW MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN WHEN.
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK-SILVA
RAMOS REYES THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SEYARTO SMITH. STONE
TEAM BALLOT THERE IS V. APPROVED
LAW VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER
WICKS. WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS OF A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER THE DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED. BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPMAN. CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR
KHAN. SEVEN IN THE NAME OF GOD.
THE MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST
MERCIFUL. ALMIGHTY GOD. WATCH
OVER THOSE WHO STAND IN THIS
CHAMBER. KEEP THEM EVER MINDFUL
OF OUR EXPECTATIONS AND THE
TRUST WE PLACE IN THEM. GIVE
THEM WISDOM FOR THEIR ACTIONS
AND GRANT TO EACH OF THEM WHEN
THEY LEAVE THE CHICKEN DISH
CHAMBER DALY. THE JOY OF BEING
ABLE TO SAY THAT THEIR WORDS AND
THE MEDITATIONS OF THEIR HEARTS
ARE ACCEPTABLE IN YOUR SIGHT.
AND THEREBY TRULY KNOW. THAT
THERE ARE A BLESSING. TO THOSE
OF US FOR HOME BASED ON YOUR- I
MEAN. THANK YOU MOM WE ASKOUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DR KILO WEBER AS YOU
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG.
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
ASSEMBLY GYM SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY MARCH SIXTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TO THE ASSEMBLY MET AT
SEVEN AM THE HONORABLE MARC
LEVINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER DENTISTS
ARE PROVIDING CHEAP LOOKS TO
PROGRAM A DESK READING CLERK
DAVID BOWMAN READING ROLL CALL
OF FALLEN WE REPLACED ONE
MORNING ROLL CALL SIXTY EIGHT.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA. MR
GALLAGHER SECOND THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL WILL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING ON TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
MISTRANSLATED NUYS AT YOUR DESK
. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS AG WE ARE CURRY
BRIAN AND GABRIEL TO SPEAK ON
AND ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL
BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE IT ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
WEBER AND BURNER HORROR ABOUT TO
HAVE GUESTS SEATED AT THEIR
DESKS TODAY. I TO HAVE A
PHOTOGRAPHER ON THE FLOOR
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FIFTY SIX TO ALLOW THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE TO SET AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY NINE BONTA.
FOR THEIR HEARING ON WEDNESDAY
APRIL TWENTIETH. TENDING RE
REFERRAL TO THE BANKING AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE HAVE
GUESTS WITH US ON THE FLOOR AND
IN THE GALLERY TODAY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH IS JOINED
AT HER DESK WITH HER DAUGHTER
MAYA. INDUCTOR WEBER IS JOINED
AT HER DESK BY HER SON'S QADEER
AND GIULIO. WELCOME MY DEAR AND
GIULIO. JOINING US IN THE
GALLERY ART TULE RIVER TRIBAL
CHAIR NEIL PAYROLL AND VICE
CHAIR SHINE NEED TO ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS WELCOME.
ALSO JOINING US IN THE GALLERY
IS THE LEWIS CENTER FOR
EDUCATIONAL RESEARCH OF APPLE
VALLEY. ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH WELL DONE. MOVING
ON TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING FILE ITEMS ONE
THREE TWENTY THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 217-627-2716
TWENTY SEVEN WITH A MOMENT
SIXTEEN SEVENTY WITH A MEMBERS
TWENTY SEVENTY NINE WITH A
MEMBERS TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE
WITH A MEMBERS TWENTY FOUR FOR
THE MEMBERS TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
SIX. THE MOMENT 1-625-164-0116
531-661-1820 418-402-1960
824-401-2270 FOR THE MEMBERS
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR WITH A
MEMBERS TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX
MINUTES AND SENATE BILL FIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN. ALL BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND ALL AMENDMENTS
WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED. FOR
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEM TWENTY
ONE SHELBY CONTINUED. ON THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
ITEMS TWENTY TWO THROUGH TWENTY
FIVE SHALL BE PASSED AND RETAIN
. WE'LL MOVE ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX ACR. ONE SIXTY ONE
SIXTY FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
OTHER THAT IS. THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BALLOT ERRORS
RELATIVE TO WORLD AUTISM
AWARENESS DAY ASSEMBLY. YOUR
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY
I RISE PROUDLY TO PRESENT ACR
ONE SIXTY FIVE WHICH
COMMEMORATES APRIL SECOND AS
WORLD AUTISM AWARENESS DAY.
AUTISM IS BECOMING ONE OF THE
MOST COMMON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AFFECTING PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. TWENTY TWENTY THE
UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
REPORTED THAT APPROXIMATELY ONE
OUT OF EVERY FIFTY FOUR CHILDREN
IN THE UNITED STATES IS
DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM. AUTISM
AFFECTS PEOPLE FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS BUT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES DUE TO THE COST AN
INACCESSIBILITY OF NECESSARY
RESOURCES. INDIVIDUALS WITH
AUTISM OFTEN REQUIRE A LIFETIME
OF SPECIALIZED MEDICAL AND
COMMUNITY SUPPORT SERVICES TO
INSURE THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY.
AS A RESULT MEICAL EXPENSES FOR
CHILDREN WITH AUTISM ARE
TYPICALLY FOUR TO SIX TIMES
GREATER THAN THEIR PEERS.
ADDITIONALLY YOUNG ADULTS WITH
AUTISM ARE LESS LIKELY TO
CONTINUE THEIR EDUCATION PASSED
SECONDARY SCHOOL AND 25% DO NOT
HAVE A JOB OR PURSUE HIGHER
EDUCATION AFTER LEAVING HIGH
SCHOOL. BECAUSE OF ITS
PREVALENCE AND THE COSTS ARE TO
AUTISM COMPOSE IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE DEDICATE
TIME TO HELPING CALIFORNIANS
BETTER UNDERSTAND THIS
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE PRIORITIZE FULLY
FUNDING OUR DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES SYSTEMS AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS TO ENSURE
THAT FAMILIES REGARDLESS OF
INCOME ARE ABLE TO FIND QUALITY
RESOURCES FOR THEIR CHILDREN
WITH AUTISM. IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT WE IN THE LEGISLATURE WORK
ON MEASURES THAT IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR THOSE WITH
AUTISM AND THEIR FAMILIES SO
THAT THEY CAN ALL REACH THEIR
FULL POTENTIAL. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR MANY OF US
BECAUSE IT TOUCHES THE LIVES OF
MANY OF OUR KEY CONSTITUENTS AND
EVEN IMPACTS SOME OF US DIRECTLY
. I KNOW THIS FIRST HAND. ABOUT
SIXTEEN YEARS AGO GO I WAS
SITTING IN THE BACK OF A CAR
WITH MY MOM ARE SITTING IN THE
FRONT F THE CAR WITH MY MOM AND
IN THE BACKSEAT WAS MY TWO YEAR
OLD SLEEPING NIECE. WHO OUT OF
NO WHERE WOKE UP CRYING. BECAUSE
SHE WAS COLD. UT SHE COULDN'T
EXPRESS THAT. LATER SHE WOULD
BECOME DIAGNOSED AS SEVERELY
DEVELOPMENTALLY DELAYED
NONVERBAL AND ON THE AUTISM
SPECTRUM IT WAS A LITTLE GIRL
THAT HAD NOT ONE WORD IN HER
VOCABULARY. THAT COULDN'T WAKE
UP FROM THAT CAR AND SAY NOT
APATHY A SISSY I'M COLDS. AFTER
HER DIAGNOSIS IN HER IMMERSION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES
THAT LITTLE GIRL WOULD COME TO
TALK AND BE A CHATTERBOX WHO WE
JOKE HAS NOT STOPPED TALKING. IT
WAS THE MAYOR WATCHING A MIRACLE
HAPPEN BEFORE OUR EYES AND THERE
ARE SO MANY FAMILIES LIKE LIKE
MINE THATNEED THAT EARLY
DIAGNOSIS THAT NEED THE
RESOURCES BUT IT'S NOT JUST
CHILDREN IT'S A LIFETIME
SPECTRUM DISORDER. STARDOLL NEED
SERVICES OUR SENIORS WITH AUTISM
NEED SERVICES AND WE HAVE THE
POWER IN THIS BODY CHU DRESS
THIS ISSUE TO BRING MORE
SERVICES TO PEOPLE ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM. I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHETHER THAT S. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE BALLOT ISSUE
MAKE CLOSE. MEMBERS I HOPE TODAY
THE ALL OF YOU WERE WEARING BLUE
ARE DOING YOUR PART TODAY AND ON
ON APRIL SECOND TO SHINE A LIGHT
ON AUTISM AN AUTISM AWARENESS
BUT WEAR BLUE THE ENTIRE MONTH
OF APRIL IF YOU'D LIKE ON APRIL
SECOND. TALK ABOUT IT AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY ACTS WHEN WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY HERE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE THE ROLE TO BE
OPENED FOR COAUTHORS. YES THANK
YOU. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS VERY
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE TO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
TO DESIRE TO VOTES. MEMBERS THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE WITHOUT IT
THERE ARE SIXTY CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL NOW
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY
NO. THE AYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION PASSES. THANK YOU.
WE'LL MOVE ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN. H. R.NINETY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES THE
CLERK WILL READ HOUSE RESOLUTION
NINETY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
SINCE OUR SERVICE THERE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAIRS HERE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AS A MEMBER OF
THE LATINO CAUCUS AND ON THEIR
BEHALF I RISE TO PRESENT H. R.
NINETY SEVEN WHICH HONORS THE
LIFE AND LEGACY OF SO SADDAM IS
THAT EITHER CHAVEZ. CHEN
CHAVEZ'S LIFE SERVES AS AN
EXTRAORDINARY EXAMPLE OF HOW ONE
PERSON CAN CHANGE. AND HAVE A
HUGE IMPACT ON ALL OF OUR LIVES
. HE WAS A SYMBOL OF JUSTICE AND
EDUCATOR OF CIVIL AND HUMAN
RIGHTS A ROLE MODEL AND A
BELOVED FRIEND OF MANY. SO
TRAVIS IS KNOWN FOR FIGHTING FOR
FARMWORKERS RIGHTS. BUT WHAT HE
REALLY DID WAS FIGHT FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS. THE RIGHT TO LIVE
WITHOUT OPPRESSION THE RIGHT TO
WORK WITHOUT HARM THE RIGHT TO
BE TREATED AS ANY OTHER HUMAN
BEING. HE FORGED A NATIONAL
COALITION OF UNIONS CHURCH
GROUPS STUDENTS MINORITIES AND
CONSUMERS. THROUGH THE USE OF
BOYCOTTS AND SPIRITUAL FASTS
SINCE I WAS ABLE TO GAIN
INVALUABLE RIGHTS FOR SOME OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN
OU